[Música]
a
bueno buenas tardes y bienvenidos ya me
han presentado a que tenemos una cosita
les vengo a traer particularmente esto
esta es la representación de la molécula
del agua
en un momento me puse a pensar en muchos
momentos me puse a pensar y en una de
mis clases
pongo esto digamos en la pizarra dibujo
esta estructura en la pizarra y
explicaba que ello dedicó gran parte de
mi tiempo de mi vida a esta molécula al
agua mi trabajo mis investigaciones
versan en el agua uno de mis estudiantes
me estuvo mirando fijamente en su
momento y después me levantó la mano y
me hizo una pregunta en realidad fue una
intervención me dice me mira fijamente y
me dice profe usted se conforma con tan
poco
y en realidad lo que quiso decirme no es
que me conformaba con tampoco ella lo
que me quiso decir es que era tan feliz
con tan poco y ahí entendí lo que es
realmente me quiso decir
y hasta así lo agradecí
de esta molécula que les acabo de
señalar depende nuestra vida algo tan
extremadamente sencillo una estructura
de tria atómica con un ángulo en el
medio nuestra vida depende de eso
la situación del agua en córdoba aunque
no sepamos la mayoría de los cordobeses
tomamos agua de dos cuencas hídricas muy
importantes el dique san roque y el
dique los molinos proveen de agua al 100
por ciento de la población de córdoba y
el tema es que el 70 por ciento de la
del agua que tomamos proviene de que
sean roque y el 30% restante proviene
del dique los molinos el dique san roque
provee la zona norte y el dique los
molinos a la zona sur de la ciudad de
córdoba y todos tomamos esa agua y ahí
tenemos algunas situaciones bastante
recurrentes en los últimos años y en los
últimos años más todavía respecto a cómo
se ve digamos
una alfombra verde mucha proliferación
de algas esa alfombra que permanece
hasta en algunos momentos de color azul
que hasta asusta un poco más porque
llevamos esto que de dónde viene a qué
planeta pertenece pertenece al nuestro
es el problema y lo tenemos no sólo en
nuestro planeta en nuestra localidad
digamos lo tenemos en la provincia lo
tenemos bastante cerca y no solamente
que lo tenemos cerca sino que nosotros
tomamos eso
el tema está dado en que eso que se vea
azul corresponde a lo menos peligroso
inclusive todavía porque eso pertenece o
corresponde a las algas muertas ya
cambian de pigmentación entonces ya no
se ve más verde pero asusta y lo verde
también nos resulta llamativo el tema es
que ahí vemos una foto bien actualizada
de algo casi monumental que esta nueva
autovía que está ahí cerca del embalse
el dique san roque en villa carlos paz y
debajo de esa obra monumental una des
obra monumental un abandono total
el puente no lo podemos tomar solamente
para transitar al agua la tenemos que
beber y nuestra vida depende de ello
es el problema
nosotros hemos puesto la mirada de
manera macro no nosotros nos asusta el
color verde del agua nos asusta el color
azul que toma el agua pero no nos
fijamos en aquello que es realmente el
problema y que no se ve qué
está acá eso están extremadamente bonito
que se ve es la microcystis una micro
existe es un alga microscópica una de
las siete u ocho variedades o más de
algas tóxicas presentes en las cuencas
hídricas de córdoba y esta es una
micrografía de mi laboratorio tomada y
puntualizada allí
volviendo al foco general el problema es
que bueno hay cuestiones que podemos
solucionar y hay cuestiones que no
nosotros vemos a esas plantas verdes
vemos esa alfombra verde sobre la
superficie del agua que en realidad no
es el verdadero problema el verdadero
problema no se ve y que es este que está
allí
la microcystis
justamente está nuevamente ahí cerca
nuestro para poder dar cuenta que el
problema es mucho menor la microcystis
de esta alga que microscópica que genera
una toxina que es la microcistina y que
esa toxina es tan peligrosa porque se
absorbe por piel o sea nosotros podemos
evitar el consumo de agua pero usamos el
agua para lavar utilizamos el agua para
el aseo personal utilizamos el agua para
en general para un montón de uso para
cocinar entonces no podemos prescindir
del consumo del agua hay algunas
cuestiones que tenemos que tener en
cuenta que corresponden a el
comportamiento de la microcystis y que
es una alga microscópica como les había
mencionado entre 78 variedades y genera
lo más preocupante que es una toxina que
es la microcistina
qué es esta que se absorbe por piel y
que aquí se las presentó esta es la
famosa microcistina a diferencia de esta
molécula que les había mencionado tan
extremadamente simple nuestra vida
depende de esta molécula tan simple y
pequeña y nuestra muerte depende de una
molécula es mucho más compleja de
entender que casi no le podríamos
nombrar
poniéndole un nombre simpático como
microcistina solamente el tema de la
microcistina es que en la mayoría de los
casos el agua que nosotros consumimos
que puedo hacer yo como un consumidor
que tengo que este
como me manejo ahí tenemos la dinámica
de esta molécula para presentársela y
verle el perfil porque es muy bonita
está terriblemente bonita aquí por
ejemplo la mayoría de los comunes que
podemos hacer la mayoría de los métodos
aplicados al agua es la cloración del
agua el hervor del agua que pasa con la
cloración la cloración elimina bacterias
agentes patógenos hongos pero la toxina
no es un agente vivo una molécula es una
sustancia por lo cual al no tener vida
no le puedo matar entonces la cloración
genera que la toxina no se modifique
siga activa en el caso de el hervor del
agua el calentamiento del agua si sirve
para eliminar sustancias estos estos
agentes me refiero a patógenos bacterias
hongos pero por el contrario y es lo que
me llevó a estudiar esta molécula tan
particular es que el calentamiento del
agua no solamente que permite que la
molécula siga activa sino que además se
vuelve más tóxica de lo que era sin
árbol sin haber hervido el agua
así que si pensamos que el estrés mata
no pensamos que pasó con tomamos mate
volviendo al foco central entonces
nuestras cuencas hídricas son como un
vaso de precipitados hay un re
cristalizador donde los deferentes
cloacales de las localidades aledañas
suelen hacer su aporte sin tratamiento
alguno además la deforestación los
incendios que estamos viviendo
actualmente generan mineralización pero
suelos que son arrastrados y llevados y
contribuyen significativamente a la
generación y a la proliferación cómoda
de estos microorganismos y toxinas las
ciencia se está encargando de eso pero
qué está haciendo este investigador este
científico respecto a esta problemática
puntual porque ustedes me escucharán o
habrán escuchado las condiciones del
agua en córdoba y pase esto es bueno
pero yo que hago abre la canilla sale
eso y lo veo lo tomo no lo tomo lo
hiervo no lo hierba le pongo cloro no
hago nada salgo corriendo que hago si lo
más probable y lo más saludable sería
salir corriendo pero bueno se saturarían
las rutas nos podríamos andar etcétera
etcétera y si tomamos la autovía nueva
seguramente que caeríamos al problema y
lo más probable entonces seguramente lo
que tenemos que hacer
filtrar pensemos en filtrar
que tengo que filtrar y qué
características tiene que tener el
filtro perfecto pero no un filtro
perfecto para cualquier cosa un filtro
perfecto para esta situación el tema
está dado en que un filtro tiene algunas
algunos comportamientos y que compiten
allí en esto de la absorción versus la
absorción la absorción es un fenómeno
superficial físico químico la absorción
un fenómeno físico que no es suficiente
que hacen los filtros convencionales un
filtro no orgánico versus un filtro dual
que es lo que estoy planteando un filtro
con características orgánicas y no
orgánicas de manera tal de que el agua
pase a través de él no me lo lleve no me
lo arrastre no se disuelva el material y
así todo pueda filtrar la toxina tiene
que filtrar retener e inactivar el
problema
y hay una relación de costos versus el
beneficio por supuesto acá les presento
entonces la bit oksibil y está que es
este material que estoy desarrollando y
que tengo en mis manos en realidad en
esas manos que son las mías pero están
ahí este y vendría a ser este filtro
perfecto que es una red cristalina que
tiene una estructura un soporte
particular intersticios que se pueden
observar ahí que están creados este
material no existe justamente lo he
fabricado lo he creado para poder tratar
de dar una solución concreta a esta
problemática puntual y hay una sinergia
de la potenciación con el uso de este
tipo de material que es la de tóxica
acá tenemos entonces qué pasaría el
material retiene la toxina y el agua
puede seguir tranquilamente su curso sin
arrastrarme el material y sin arrastrar
la toxina imagínense que una de las
toxinas que genera una de las variedades
de entre las 7 y 8 variedades de algas
que también generan toxinas o sea
solamente estoy tocando un punto y
porque ustedes me preguntarán por qué no
estudia toda buena una cuestión de
presupuesto la vida me está llevando la
vida a la mole ccoo del agua imagínense
de la microcystis no me alcanza entonces
por lo menos es una parte ir tratando
dar solución dar respuesta a algo que si
este filtro y este material funciona
para una de esas toxinas es probable que
funcione para otras
entonces acá tenemos una relación muy
clara respecto a la unidad de medida de
las cosas que hay que hacer a las cuenca
griego porque qué hacemos en
consecuencias bueno hay que hacer una
serie de cosas en función del tiempo y
es la aplicabilidad la aplicabilidad de
los métodos de optimización del agua
bueno a medida que pase el tiempo se van
volviendo menos aplicables y hay una
relación inversa con el costo mientras
menos aplicable se vuelvan estos métodos
más costosos son obviamente sí mientras
menos aplicables son y más costosos
menos se va a tratar de poner en marcha
una solución
hoy donde estamos parados bueno estamos
parados por ahí y para ser generosos en
realidad estamos mucho más cerca del
punto de inflexión con lo cual se vuelve
crítica la situación porque mientras más
cerca del punto de inflexión estamos
casi casi que se está volviendo el
problema un poquito más irreversible
entonces hay que seguir trabajando en
esto esta cuestión del deterioro también
en función del tiempo estas variables
físico-químicas y micro biológicas que
acompañan al deterioro de las cuencas
hídricas del agua en particular en el
san roque han sido siempre lineales eso
qué quiere decir que el san roque
siempre se deterioro de la misma manera
con el paso del tiempo eso no es una
cuestión agradable pero ha sido
coherente mientras que el dique los
molinos ha tenido un deterioro
exponencial es decir se ha venido
deteriorando mucho más rápido de lo que
le ha costado deteriorarse o lo que se
ha deteriorado el dique san roque
habiendo sido el dique los molinos de
los principales espejos de agua y más
puro que tenía la provincia de córdoba y
conjugue bien era mejor dicho fue
por lo tanto el esfuerzo tiene que ser
múltiples mancomunado las zonas y las
localidades aledañas estas cuencas
hídricas que utilizan explotan el
recurso y no lo aprovechan sino que se
aprovechan de él son las principales
responsables y un esfuerzo mancomunado
repartido permite que las acciones sean
mucho más aplicables menos costosas y
que podamos abrir la canilla y estemos
tranquilos de que lo que está saliendo
por ahí es agua y no otra cosa y tiene
que ser sistemático ese esfuerzo
sistemático y sostenido en el tiempo
permite que logremos de alguna manera
alguna solución que sea viable y
permanente porque las soluciones que no
sean combinadas de esta manera no
terminan siendo soluciones terminan
siendo paliativos que en definitiva
terminan llevando a la situación tal
como la conocemos hoy por lo tanto y
como digo siempre el esfuerzo tiene que
ser de todos y el futuro del agua está
en nuestras manos
en sus manos está en mis manos está en
nuestras manos nos tenemos que hacer
responsables todos desde nuestro lugar
porque podemos hacerlo y no solamente
podemos tenemos que todo este
conocimiento y toda esta cuestión que
queda guardada en el laboratorio corre
el riesgo de volverse total y
absolutamente inútil por eso estoy aquí
para poder compartir un poquito de este
conocimiento y brindar una parte de la
solución pero no olvidemos que el futuro
del agua está en nuestras manos así que
como en general vive les digo a todos
cuidemos entre todos el agua muchas
gracias
[Música]